do you know part of the reason why we
can't game out putin or we can't game
out xi jinping or we can't
act like responsible serious people on
the world stage because we can't even
figure out what a woman is and we can't
figure out what a man is and we're
wasting all of our time debating these
stupid things that even a five-year-old
knows that we no longer know the genius
adults running our country no longer
know
this is this is one of the reason that
that we need settled norms
there are many there are many good
things about having settled norms
one of them is
that we don't waste our time
a society that doesn't know
what a man is and what a woman is
cannot advance to more complicated
questions it's sort of like in school
you've got to learn two plus two equals
four
before you can start looking at
trigonometry or more advanced algebra or
calculus
you can't do those things until you
figure out the basics if you're
constantly stuck at the basics
of statecraft of the relationship of the
individual to the state and to each
other you're not going to be able to
advance to more complex questions and
then what's going to happen your enemies
are going to eat your lunch
these questions of norms
are largely why the movie light year
just flopped at the box office over the
weekend which
not to say i told you so but i did
predict that that would happen
the the light year movie is the the
latest toy story movie it's a prequel
and unlike the earlier toy story movies
which generally are good certainly the
first one is terrific i think number two
is good too i don't think i saw number
three
or was there a fourth or might have been
a fourth i'd but they generally have
been good movies and then this one
they fire tim allen who's the voice of
buzz lightyear and they fire him because
he's a conservative it's
the only reason that makes sense they
didn't fire him because he was too
expensive they hired a more expensive
actor to do it chris evans but chris
evans is a huge lib and tim allen is an
outspoken conservative so they fire tim
allen and then they insist on on
inserting a lesbian kiss scene
they insist and it had initially been
cut but then the gay
organization of disney employees got
very upset that it was cut and so for
pride month and to spite governor ron
desantis they reinserted a lesbian kiss
scene and then a bunch of conservative
parents and normal parents and centrist
parents and center-left parents even
said no
no i don't think so because it's it's
not even just because we don't want to
see lesbian toys kiss
it's because it's not toy story
it's because whatever this thing is i i
know it looks like toy story it's got
the same characters and the same colors
and the same animation but it's not toy
story now it's there it's the left using
toy story which is a nice wholesome
normal story
to push its own woke ideology the box
office estimates
dropped 35 35 in one day
early friday morning heading into the
weekend
the estimated box office was 85 million
dollars domestic then by the end of the
day the estimates had dropped down to 55
million the actual close was 51 million
the estimates for the global box office
was 135 million
then dropped down to
85.6
million dollars way way down wasn't even
the biggest movie of the weekend so much
money went into this movie so much hype
went into this movie didn't even clear
the biggest movie of the weekend the
biggest movie of the weekend was the new
jurassic park movie which did not open
this past weekend it opened the weekend
previously so the second weekend for
jurassic park was better than the first
weekend for the new toy story movie why
it's obviously just because of this
fight over norms and over the gay kiss
and the liberal actor playing buzz
lightyear and it's because the left has
misunderstood america's penchant for
tolerance
americans are very tolerant
but we do not want to normalize
much of the stuff that we tolerate
there's a difference between
toleration and normalization
and the libs are banking on american
tolerance
in their campaign to normalize all sorts
of behaviors but we don't want to
normalize that stuff americans like our
norms
americans are happy to tolerate
people especially on the sex issues
people's eccentric sexual desires and
behaviors
everybody's got a gay cousin or
something and no one really cares right
we all just sort of tolerate it it's
fine okay it's not a big deal
but we don't want
the lgbt
ideology being taught to our kids in
public schools in libraries in the
movies we don't want that we're happy to
tolerate we'll tolerate
the the drag queen at the bar in
greenwich village
we'll tolerate that that exists we don't
really care
we will not allow that behavior to be
normalized we'll tolerate transgenderism
in the sense that
if there's a mentally ill man who thinks
that he's a woman
we're not going to go out of our way to
get in his face and say no you're you're
actually a man
we're not we're not going to do it if
ben you remember ben shapiro went viral
some years ago because he was on tv and
this transgender dude was just getting
all up in his face and yelling at him
and ben said well what are your what are
your
genetic characteristic sir right he was
being provocative because it was a tv
show but he wasn't he actually wasn't
the one provoking the situation
it was that wasn't an example of ben
being intolerant i'm sure that if ben
has said this himself if he were at a
dinner party and some dude in a dress
asked to be called she he would oblige
in the moment in the dinner party
but what is being asked by
the tv debates over transgenderism and
the the transgender ideology in
classrooms and libraries and movies is
not toleration it's normalization it's
not just hey will you in your charity in
your grace in your politeness
indulge
some delusions of people at a dinner
party
will you tolerate this strange behavior
it is the demand that we actually lie
and we actually pretend that it is
normal for a man to think that he's a
woman and that the man actually is a
woman we're not going to do that okay
and i'm not just speaking for the
right-wing conservatives here america is
just not going to do that and that's why
the buzz lightyear movie is not making a
lot of money and it's why there's a
parents movement in virginia in florida
all around the country and the democrats
are shocked by this
they're shocked because they overplayed
their hand and yet the libs keep pushing
this joe biden
in a
pride month remarks uh just came out and
he said the ultra maga people now we're
the weird ones because we're going after
mickey mouse because we don't we don't
want lgbt
propaganda in the disney movies
no one knows better than the people in
this room we have a lot more work to do
a lot more work to do i don't have to
tell you about the ultra maga agenda
attacking families and our freedoms 300
discriminatory bills introduced in
states across this country in texas
knocking on front doors to harass and
investigate parents who are raising
transgender children in florida going
after mickey mouse for god's sake
[Music]
that's very close to home
now but think about this
all of you in this room know better than
anyone that these attacks are real and
consequential for real families
ha ha ha ha they're going after mickey
mouse for yeah because mickey mouse
isn't mickey mouse anymore
just like buzz lightyear is in buzz
lightyear anymore
this is what you're what you might you
might look like mickey mouse
he might have the
sound of mickey mouse but the things
that mickey is pushing
are radical
leftist propaganda
men could really be women
little kids should chop off their body
parts
and take puberty blockers oh and that
funny goofy huh no man that's what ar
you're like a weird demon mickey you're
not the real mickey you're some bizarro
world mickey that has been hollowed out
and had the essence of mickey taken out
of it and so
what the left banks on is people's
now generational affection for the
disney characters
which have now been murdered and have
been hollowed out and the leftist
virus has crawled inside and reanimated
it's its corpse and it is just used to
push radicalism that's that's what
disney is is under fire for that's what
florida is pushing back against
florida says don't teach five-year-olds
weird sex stuff
disney says we're gonna put all the
weight of our gigantic
multinational corporation behind a
campaign to undermine the voters of
florida and then florida says no you're
not now we're going to actually take
away some of your tax incentives we're
going to fight back we're not going to
let you do that
and so the white house takes the side of
the big woke crazy multinational
corporation trying to groom the kids
and it's not working desantis is very
popular in florida the politicians
around the country who are taking the
side of parents and opposing the
corporations
are winning and this is great news for
desantis by the way this is real i mean
ron desantis is one of the most talented
young politicians i've ever seen this
guy
somehow is at the center of every
national news story and joe biden
clearly sees him as a threat that's why
that's why the sitting president of the
united states the incumbent who at least
says that he's going to run for
re-election keeps going after desantis
i'm glad you like that clip now hold on
ring the bell you know please subscribe
like do all that subscribe on apple
podcast leave a five-star review and
then copy this url right now wherever
you are on your app and you can copy
that url got it now text it
to three of your best friends
i
i am concerned as a philanthropist i
have heard that there are actually still
some people who do not listen to or
watch the michael knowles show and this
is very sad these people are deprived
you can change that right now you've got
it in your power text it email it to
your friends your relatives do an act of
kindness and charity today we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]